bonjour lucas alors quels sont les
enjeux de cette rencontre
et bien se sont succédé pendant cette
journée est celle d'hier et se
succéderont demain des journalistes des
personnalités politiques des lanceurs d
alerte bien sûr dans des tables rondes
sur tous les sujets de la société
l'écologie les violences policières
l'économie autant de sujets dans
lesquels des lanceurs d'alerté ont joué
des rôles prépondérants ces dernières
années c'est un événement qui est
soutenue par plusieurs organisations
notamment anticorps greenpeace la ligue
des droits de l'homme où la maison des
lanceurs d'alerté cette année et bien
c'est une année un peu particulière
parce que plane encore des incertitudes
sur le cas de julian assange qui
risquent 175 ans de prison aux états
unis n'est pas encore sûr de ne pas être
extradé aux états unis les procédures
sont encore en cours vous l'avez dit il
y avait john shipton le père julian
assange tout à l'heure pour la diffusion
du film hacking justice j'ai pu
m'entretenir avec le réalisateur de ce
film je vous propose d'écouter ce qu'il
m'a dit
je pense que julian assange ne devrait
pas être en prison si on prend en compte
que la justice britannique a statué
contre son extradition qu'en ce moment
il n'y a qu'une procédure d'appel contre
lui et que son état de santé comme l'ont
témoigné plusieurs médecins qui l'ont
examinée est grave
c'est la raison pour laquelle il ne
l'extraderait pas et ça fait bientôt 12
ans de détention cumulé une détention
que l'onu a considéré comme arbitraire
avec tout d'abord l'assignation à
résidence à londres et maintenant dans
la prison de haute sécurité il faut
mettre fin à cette situation
présent aussi dans la salle le député
cédric villani qui est venu apporter son
soutien à julian assange je vous propose
d'écouter ce qu'il m'a dit
inscrit dans l'histoire de la france de
façon glorieuses il y à la liberté de
parole la liberté d'expression liberté
de journalisme
ce n'est pas un hasard si l'une des
récompenses reçues par julian assange
s'appelle le prix voltaire 2 2 pour la
liberté d'expression
et il ya là quelque chose qui résonne
très fort avec notre histoire c'est bien
pour cela que nous avons été des députés
de tous les bords politiques à signer la
proposition de résolution demandant
qu'on offre l'asile à julian assange
cette rencontre aussi a une résonance
particulière cette année puisque va être
discutée la semaine prochaine à
l'assemblée nationale une proposition de
loi du député modem sylvain waserman qui
vise à renforcer le statut des lanceurs
d alerte renforcer les dispositifs déjà
présent dans la loi c'est en partie la
transposition d'une directive européenne
de 2000 19 sur la question mais il a
précisé hier que la loi était beaucoup
plus ambitieuse le 4 novembre en amont
de ce débat des représentants des ong et
des syndicalistes ont signé une tribune
dans le monde pour rappeler à quel point
les lanceurs d'alerté était important
dans la démocratie ils ont rappelé que
douze propositions avaient été faites
pour mieux les protéger en france le
député va zorman en a récupéré quelques
unes de ses idées dans sa proposition de
loi il reste à savoir maintenant comment
ce texte va évoluer devant l'assemblée
nationale
merci lucas pour toutes ces précisions